oh my grers
worldwide keep your head
up
fin de journée à Saint-Louis pour vous
parler d'un sport collectif qui compte
près de 300 licenciés 6 clubs qui
participent au championnat de France
National 4 et pour nous en parler et toi
ta passion c'est quoi c'est le ça
glisse David est le Mauricien du circuit
une enfance métropolitaine lui a fait
épouser cette passion dès l'âge de 6
ans j'ai vu une fois du h avec normal ça
m'a attiré du coup j'ai fait ça et puis
je suis rest accroché à ça en
faitant plus grand je me suis je cherche
un sport qu'est-ce que je vais faire
machinalement c'est la glace est
arriv
je expliquer après on fait un
échauffement pour l'instant j'explique
le parcours après on s'échauffe le
tour là on vient là sal par d'ici on
croise pour ceux qui savent
croiser et on finit
là-bas c'est
bon le vendredi soir les marmaill sont
en plein action et comme vous le
constatez il y a des petits il y a des
grands car ici il jouit entre
camarad moi fait ça pour amuser à moi et
pour pour amuser à moi à gagner à
jouer quand quand on est à fond
ça va pu arrêter ben ça dans la tête
vous ça ah ça
moi dans ce quartier considéré comme
difficile l'aide à l'équipement est
essentielle là vous tombez sur un
bonjour les enfants sont enfin équipés
sont normalement équipé grâce à la
région qui a donné une qui a donné une
subvention à la Ligue pour acheter du
matériel qui a été réparti dans les
différents clubs ça veut dire que la
semaine dernière enfin il y a 15 15
jours 3 semaines les les enfants n'avait
aucune protection on est un club de
proximité dans un quartier sensible et
qui
est on va dire plutôt de catégorie
défavorisé le ho peut leur apporter de
la rigueur et puis aussi un brassage un
brassage de mixité
sociale